you know many people think all genuinely
loving relationships are asymmetrical
one person loves more than the other and
that may very well be true I believe
that that to be true it's it's less than
ideal but it's often the case that two
people love each other but one person
cares more one person has more at stake
emotionally does that make the
relationship in some sense a moral no I
don't think so there's the duty to be
honest to treat another person's heart
with tenderness but you can't demand
utter symmetry after that the other
person is for all practical purposes and
adult and he gets to decide if given the
nature of the relationship he wants to
participate in it you know even though
Emmylou Harris never has me over for
dinner never returns my phone calls and
then there's the damn court order that
that I still think it's a valuable
relationship to continue so I still
listen to her music
you know all's fair in love and war is
one of 50 different bits of jargon that
we use to justify the incredible
selfishness that can often go along with
love but if it's working really well
simply by pleasing yourself you please
the other person you know it's an
impossible golden jury that it's at
least something aspirational in your
erotic life that you're not doing things
you yourself hate simply as a favor to
the other person the in general for the
most part by doing what you genuinely
enjoy in bed that gives a great deal of
pleasure to the other person I'm not
utopian about this there's all sorts of
things we do for one another as gifts
you know sexual gifts not things we
despise that things we detest but things
all right this isn't my first choice of
what will you be doing now but I do it
because you like it and there's pleasure
in pleasing the beloved so so be
generous spirit it in been and out of it
be generous spirited in your erotic life
and in your heart but the more simply by
being yourself you give pleasure to the
other person the greater the odds of
your having a happy sex life and a happy
emotional life
you